ah the job search whether it's your
first job or your fifth job
the process can be very frustrating and
confusing so in this series i'm gonna
try to cover
everything you need to know when you're
applying for an architecture job
including how to build your portfolio
how to put that portfolio online
how to write your resume and your cover
letter the importance of having an
online presence
and also some interview tips and how to
talk about your work
and your experience but in today's video
we will be talking about the most
important thing of all
the portfolio
hey guys welcome back to the channel if
you're new here
my name is dani and i'm a licensed
architect in beautiful
vancouver bc on this channel we talk
about architecture and design
and also some tools and strategies that
can help you have more meaningful
and fulfilling careers in architecture
so what exactly is a portfolio
a portfolio is simply the most important
artifact of your existence
as an architect but seriously guys
without a portfolio
you will not get anywhere in
architecture
it's a professional statement of who you
are what you like
how you work and it's going to speak for
you when you're not there
so no matter what stage of your
education or career you're in
you should be constantly thinking about
how what you're doing right now
can supplement your portfolio your
portfolio is going to contain
your cv or resume an about me page
and the portfolio which is the visual
collection of your work
and so today we're going to be covering
the collection of work and how to create
one through
six simple somewhat simple steps we will
go through
project selection image selection
determining a format
designing a layout designing your front
cover and also
at the end i'll show you how you can get
a hold of these templates that i've
created for you
so what are the qualities of a good
portfolio first
you have to show the process and not
just the finished work
second you have to tell a story and it's
not just a
collection of projects and third you
have to demonstrate your passion but
also
show your hard skills you will want to
strike a balance between showing your
creativity
and you know proving that you're a good
designer and
showing them that you have the skills
that is going to provide
tangible value to the firm and this part
really comes from really understanding
the position you're applying for
and what kind of person they need and
what kind of work they do
i've mostly worked at small firms so
i've reviewed a lot of portfolios and
really listened in on the interviews and
the principal's
impression of the candidate we had this
one girl who came in for an interview
and she had a beautiful portfolio full
of
water coloring and models
and she wrote a really nice personal
cover letter but although we
really liked her work and she proved her
skills as a designer
the principal got the impression that
she was too
careful and that she wouldn't be able to
work fast enough to keep up with the
project
and she was applying for an internship
position but she didn't really
show any digital modeling skills or
rendering skills
which was another downside so you just
need to try to understand
what the work you're showing implies and
try to
strike a careful balance between showing
that you're a good designer
and that you can provide that tangible
value to the firm that
that they're going to need to get the
projects rolling efficiently that story
also shows that no matter how good your
work is
you might get rejected for a reason
that's completely
unknown to you so i wouldn't get too
discouraged
so before we get into the meat of it i
just want to note here that every
portfolio and cover letter that you send
out should be
tailored to the firm that you're
applying for but you might be saying
i'm applying to 50 different firms i
don't have time to put together 50
different portfolios
to that i would say suck it up i'm just
kidding that's when
having a master portfolio can come in
really handy
it's a collection of all of your work
and that way
whenever you apply to a firm you can
just pick and choose which projects you
want to show
it takes a little bit more time to get
started but i think it can really help
you in the long run
especially if you've just graduated from
school and you
have to send out like 50 applications to
multiple firms most firms still prefer a
pdf document
but some firms prefer a hard copy
and some firms prefer a website so
before doing anything
just do your research and go check the
application requirements
in this video i'm going to be covering
the pdf format
usually you don't want to send out
anything more than
15 megabytes and nothing more than
around 40 pages yeah you might think
that that's pretty
limiting in showing the depth and
breadth of your abilities as an
architect
so a way around that is to create a
website
that showcases all of your work a
website is great because they don't need
to download anything
and people are pretty sensitive about
having to download stuff they can just
select through the projects that they
want to see
and you can also keep it up to date
pretty easily
i would suggest you can send the pdf and
just say hey this is my website if you
want to see more of my work
a website also means that it's
searchable and
apparently eighty percent of our
employers google us before an interview
so i think a personal website is
actually a must
in the 21st century but um i'll actually
cover that in my next video
so eventually once you get invited in
for an interview you're gonna need to
bring a physical
hard copy to talk about your work and i
like to use something where you can
you can swap the pages um i think i
heard someone say that this sucks but i
thought you should get
a portfolio bound i i really don't care
in the end if they're interested in my
work and the contents of my portfolio
they're not gonna be like uh but the
binder it wasn't found
and it's just gonna save me so much time
and money and
that just wins out for me so before you
start compiling your work
you just need to identify what type of
position are you going for
what type of work does this firm do what
are the responsibilities
from this you can start asking yourself
which
projects should i focus on what kind of
skills do i want to showcase
one of my mentors one time told me if
you don't want to be doing renders
don't show renders if you're going into
a project management role you're going
to show less
renderings and less visuals and
more photos of the details or
construction processes
also what level of competence does this
demonstrate
and this is gonna determine what type of
work and what kind of images you show
okay so now we're just gonna go through
this step by step
first you need to select your project
obviously you should select only your
strongest
and most relevant project but if
you are not happy with some of the work
and you see
potential in the project it is totally
fine to read you
the drawings for it when you're just
starting out your portfolio is going to
be
mostly your academic work and after
about
three to four years it should be mostly
your professional work
with one like maximum two academic work
okay so high level i'm just going to
quickly go through what you should be
striving to capture
through your projects and images so for
an academic portfolio so this would be
like your first job or your first
internship
so show hand sketching and drawing
i put this first because kind sketching
is like a secret weapon in architecture
and it can elevate any portfolio your
digital modeling skills
your drafting skills visuals that tell a
story concept design design development
site analysis creative problem solving
skills
some knowledge of construction detailing
some knowledge of sustainable design
practices
some general knowledge of zoning and the
building code any extracurricular
activities related to architecture
like journal articles or publications
and
any other interests that align closely
with architecture or
the arts and as you get further in your
career
and as you start seeking a more project
architect role
some of these things like graphics and
visuals become
less important and you really want to
focus on the type of project
and your role on the project so since
your responsibilities become
broader than just in the image creation
i think text becomes more important in
describing your role
and your involvement i had a more
creative layout
more flexible layout for my academic
portfolio but
a few years into my career i switched
into
a very simple layout with images or
photos of the project
and a little bit of text and the firm
that i did the work with
also just a side note the items in green
are things that could be captured in
your cv
photos of built or completed work if you
have any built or completed work
this is the thing that's going to
distinguish you from a recent grad
and it's going to give you a more
experienced position
and more money so you really want to
highlight this
and include this in the beginning as
much as possible if the firms had
professional photos of the project then
just ask them if you can use them but
sometimes a construction photos are just
as good as showing that
you've gone through the construction
process you should
show your level of contribution i put
this one in green
because you can show it through images
you want to be really really super clear
about this
and so by putting it in your cv as a
general note and in the project
description you can be
really clear about your role i will
cover
the cv more in depth in another video
for images
as a general rule you should only be
using images that you produced
but if it was a rendering done by
someone else then
just say that in the annotation and try
not to use
too many of them you should also note
your level of exposure on different
phases of a project
you should always indicate what stage of
the project you were involved in
if you have any projects that you've
done from the beginning to the end
no matter how small it is you kind of
want to highlight those
you want to note your knowledge of the
planning system
spec writing abilities knowledge of
construction
construction drawing abilities a good
way to show your construction drawing
skills
is side by side with a construction
photo this is a small detail i designed
on a project
and by showing it side by side with the
detail that i designed you're telling
them that
yeah you can draw details and you've
gone from design to construction
and that you have a good design sense
knowledge of sustainable design
more specifically having lead or passive
house certification can be very
beneficial it's becoming an almost uh
standard
a good knowledge of building legislation
this gets more and more important as you
get further along in your career you can
show that by
showing how you've navigated around
local bylaws
and this can be a good topic of
discussion
at the interview you should show your
software skills and your digital skills
relevant to the work that you're
applying for project management skills
teamwork this can be reinforced in your
cv or in your cover letter
any involvement in the industry like if
you were a part of the internship
council
um if you have any blogs or articles i
can be helpful
having your own website and platform you
can start creating this
so from all of that you can determine a
format
look at all the graphics you have and
pick your top three strongest projects
and from there decide how you want to
arrange your template
so here's some examples is it going to
be letter size
it's going to be legal tabloid vertical
landscape
your images will help you determine this
then you design the layout this is where
we get into the fun part
the design of your portfolio is going to
demonstrate
not just your work but also your
graphical ability
so the layout and arrangement is just
as important as the contents and i think
this is especially important for recent
grads and
like first time applicants because
you're gonna be
mostly in charge of the graphics at the
firm i would strongly recommend using
indesign this is an industry standard
and this is
it's just kind of a basic skill that
every architect should have
in order to design presentations and
proposals
so please no powerpoint if you
god forbid don't know indesign follow my
link in the description and head over to
skillshare who's kindly sponsoring this
video
and take any one of the indesign courses
right now
i promise you it's gonna save you hours
and hours of work and headache
and heartache down the line i'm sure
you've all heard of skillshare
by now it's an online learning community
with thousands of inspiring classes
where you can explore new skills or
refine existing ones
like photography sketching or graphic
design
it's also curated specifically for
learning meaning
there's no ads and they're always
launching new
premium classes so you can stay focused
and
follow wherever your curiosity takes you
also
it's less than ten dollars a month
with an annual subscription that's less
than
a meal so the first 1000 of my
subscribers to click the link with the
description
will get a free trial of the premium
membership so you can explore your
creativity
back to the list so graphically like i
mentioned in the list
try to show a wide range of media from
renderings to diagrams
to photographs of models try to
make it so that each graphic complements
and supports each other and of course
you have to be mindful
to not have a million pages firms get
hundreds of applications and in reality
they're really gonna be
very quickly scrolling through your
portfolio so if you have a very long
portfolio that can get very annoying
you should also spend some time to think
about the order of the project
you could present it chronologically
from your most
recent to the oldest or you could
present your
best and most relevant work and then
show projects that's gonna show your
supplemental skills
for one of my portfolio the first one
was related to the
building type that they do and then i
showed the one that showed the best
process and the one that showed the most
interesting design skills
and my last project was actually
competition that i did with building
science students
and although this is the weakest project
in the portfolio
because it wasn't my personal project
it showed that i'm able to work in a
interdisciplinary team and that
i have knowledge about sustainable
buildings
and that i know the fundamentals of
net zero buildings so that was very
important for this firm
that did a lot of sustainable buildings
and so yeah that was
my choice of project you should also try
to create
a sense of order within the project
maybe you could start with a simple
diagram that shows the site or the
concept and then you go into the
drawings
with titles and text and labels just
keep the font simple
have a maximum of two fonts have the
title and in the description
add like the year of the project phase
of the project
your involvement and also include small
captions for images
you can also show page numbers freeze of
navigation
and generally just try to use as little
text as possible
um just one or two paragraphs per page
and the text should work with the images
to grab people's attention
most likely your readers are not going
to be reading the text
but in this slim chance that they do
read all of the description paragraphs
just double triple check that there's no
spelling errors or grammatical errors
because that looks
really unprofessional you can leave the
front cover
to the end because you might
get inspiration from the design and the
mood of your portfolio
there are so many examples of this and
it can really depend
from person to person don't just use
your picture
i used a photo of this wood box that i
designed and made
it's minimal it shows my design
capabilities
show some materiality and shows that i
can make stuff
i felt like it was kind of abstract
enough that it could
be anything things not to include old
projects
work you didn't design obviously bad
projects boring projects or
like projects that you hate do not
include
long text um have some sort of hierarchy
in the text
like uh with headings do not show
irrelevant work experience
if you were done mcdonald's although i
personally learned a lot of applicable
life skills from mcdonald's uh do not
show that
do not show random hobbies unless you
feel it will contribute to the firm
culture
here in vancouver there's a lot of firms
where the principals are like
really really really into cycling so
if you are a cyclist you could add that
in your hobbies but otherwise
just um nobody cares about your random
hobby in general if you're
just out of school your biggest
contribution
is most likely gonna be like schematic
design
design development modeling knowledge of
the programs
this is gonna be your superpower because
a lot of the older people
at the firm they won't be as efficient
at doing visualization
like uh that's doing renderings or
diagramming or putting together
presentations
um digital modeling so really try to
show off these skills
last but not least i mentioned that i
have these portfolio templates
and it's gonna cost you what you're
gonna charge for that don't you remember
what it was like
um
okay guys so i decided to give them away
for free
i know that this is a hard process and i
just want to ease the pain a little bit
you can follow the link in the
description and download your templates
all i'm asking you to do is like and
comment on this video
you guys know how much the comments help
with the algorithm and remember this
favor
okay i hope you guys found this video
helpful and
i just want to add one last note
that sometimes the rejection doesn't
have
anything to do with you they're just
looking for someone very
specific and um
you just don't fit that role um
so don't feel too bad and just keep
trying
i'm actually not a huge fan of this
practice of being judged by your
portfolio because your worth is not
defined by your work
and that's why i'm going to be following
up with videos where you can show off
your other skills
like how to write your resume and your
cover letter and the benefits of having
an online presence and also some
interview tips and tricks
and i'll also talk about how you can
talk about your work and your experience
so let me know if you have any questions
in the comments
i'm actually not able to answer any
emails right now because i
i have an insane workload i hope you
guys can understand
but i'll definitely answer any questions
in the comment section
so with that i'll see you guys in the
next video bye
[Music]
you